[Música]
porque cada 8 de marzo se celebra el día
internacional de los derechos de la
mujer este año en mujeres lo celebra
bajo el lema igualdad de género hoy para
un mañana sostenible con nuestra primera
invitada del día vamos a analizar
entonces la situación de ellas en
nuestra región y en medio de la guerra
que se vive en ucrania en ese día las
mujeres de todo el mundo salen a las
calles de las principales ciudades para
reivindicar sus derechos derechos en
muchas ocasiones vulnerados por los
gobiernos y también la sociedad nos
enfocamos en nuestra región de américa
latina y el caribe donde las
desigualdades parecen crecer cada día
siendo las mujeres una de las
poblaciones más afectadas además
hablamos de cómo es la situación de los
derechos humanos en ellas de ellas en
esta guerra en ucrania y para ello
entonces quiero saludar a julissa
mantilla falcón ella es presidenta de la
comisión interamericana de los derechos
humanos las 6 d h gracias julissa por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 para mí es un gusto de estar
con usted hoy el día internacional de
los derechos de ustedes además la
felicito por eso y por su lucha desde su
posición hablemos entonces la situación
de las mujeres en nuestra en materia de
los derechos humanos un balance general
bueno muy buenos días en primer lugar
gracias por la entrevista creo que es
una oportunidad en este día pero no solo
en este día para más allá de felicitar a
las mujeres es conmemorar una lucha una
lucha difícil y continua ahora bien en
el caso de la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos recordar cómo
trabajamos no solamente la
implementación de la convención
americana sino también de la convención
belem do para para erradicar la
violencia contra las mujeres y en esa
línea nuestro análisis y nuestro trabajo
tanto a nivel de casos y de monitoreo
nos hable en primer lugar de una
permanente desigualdad y esta
desigualdad abarca todos los ámbitos en
la región la comisión interamericana y
lo dice hoy en su comunicado de prensa
porque internacional de la mujer insta a
los estados a la investigación pero no
solamente a la judicialización que es
importante entre las violaciones de
derechos humanos contra las mujeres sino
también a cumplir sus obligaciones
internacionales de transformar la
situación social en el acceso a las
mujeres a sus derechos económicos
sociales culturales el acceso a la
justicia el acceso una vida violencia a
su salud sexual y reproductiva las
cifras son
que realmente puede decir
sí sí alarmantes
y alarmantes no le escuchaba perdón es
alarmante pero además yo quisiera
distinguir los ámbitos por un lado
países en los cuales por ejemplo
nicaragua donde toda la situación de
falta de atenta y de atentados a la
democracia todo lo que estamos viendo
tiene también una particular afectación
a las mujeres las mujeres feministas
presas políticas en el caso del salvador
por ejemplo una legislación que penaliza
todas las formas de aborto todas
absolutamente donde hay mujeres que
están en la cárcel por 10 15 30 años
incluso por una interrupción natural por
un aborto natural espontáneo tenemos
países como en el caso de colombia donde
se dan se han dado situaciones
gravísimas
de violencia sexual durante el conflicto
armado y donde ahora es necesario
investigar y judicializar y algo que
atraviesa toda la región es el
feminicidio
yo me permite quisiera detenerme en eso
durante mucho tiempo se ha hecho y se
persiguió la tipificación del
feminicidio
no hice es una respuesta el derecho
penal la pregunta que yo haría y esa es
la reflexión para que dejemos de pensar
que el tema de los derechos de las
mujeres es un problema sólo de las
mujeres qué clase de sociedades tenemos
donde los niños y niñas huérfanos del
feminicidio siguen creciendo con esta
tragedia eterna de haber perdido a sus
madres en manos de sus padres no podemos
hablar de sociedades democráticas no
violentas cuando el feminicidio se sigue
produciendo cuando no se investiga
cuando el acceso a la justicia de las
mujeres es tan difícil conflictos y
juristas cuál es cuál es este impacto no
de la violencia en la vida de las
mujeres y de las niñas sobre todo bueno
una uno de los primeros impactos es la
imposibilidad de acceder a puestos de
decisión y de poder en condiciones de
igualdad si me permite ayer a mí me
eligieron como presidenta de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos soy
la primera mujer peruana presidente de
la comisión interamericana y durante 60
años la comisión no tuvo sino hasta el
año pasado por primera vez una directiva
sólo por mujer
la corte interamericana este año inicia
por primera vez en su historia con tres
mujeres y eso que podemos ver qué bueno
que estamos llegando también de basamos
reflexionar porque nos estamos demorando
está y yo le hago una una invitación a
reflexionar sobre la continuidad en la
violencia cuando una niña es criada
socializada como tener que prestar más
trabajo de cuidado no remunerado atender
la casa cuidar no poder estudiar no
tener otras posibilidades en su vida y
decidir libremente sobre su sexo salud
sexual y reproductiva cuando va entrando
en trabajos menos remunerados se vea
generando una ruta discriminación y un
sur círculo de violencia mujeres que por
ejemplo son violentadas y las cifras nos
hablan de una cifra una cantidad enorme
de adolescentes y niñas violadas
sexualmente y embarazadas producto de
esa violación yo pregunto una niña que a
los 13 años es violada y es obligada
hasta a dar a luz para luego poder
acceder al gobierno la presidencia a la
comisión al periodismo atender en
televisión entonces yo importante ver no
solamente el hecho concreto la violación
concreta sino todo el impacto que tiene
en nuestras vidas julissa no quiero
despedirla y que se acabe nuestra
conversación que podría durar muchísimo
tiempo además porque son temas muy
interesantes que además a mí me encanta
tocarlos pero hablemos por favor de la
vulnerabilidad de las mujeres en ese
momento en ucrania en el contexto de
guerra de la invasión de rusia a ese
país
bueno parto en primer lugar con una idea
que quisiera que quedara clara la
vulnerabilidad de las mujeres preexiste
a la guerra iba a continuar después y
continúa después de la firma de los
acuerdos de paz hablamos de una
continuidad de violencia y
discriminación en la guerra se exacerban
esas situaciones de violencia y
desigualdad y le doy un ejemplo muy
concreto soy históricamente la violencia
sexual estuvo considerada por primera
vez como un crimen de lesa humanidad y
de guerra a partir de los tribunales
penales internacionales del 93 para la
ex yugoslavia y del 94 para ruanda y a
partir del año 2000 en la corte penal
internacional su estatuto habla de
violencia sexual como crimen de lesa
humanidad o de brno yo le pregunto y le
pregunto cualquiera de las personas que
nos gusta oyendo realmente sólo se dio
violencia sexual a partir del 93 y si
hacemos una búsqueda histórica que yo
invito a realizar en la segunda guerra
mundial el estatuto de núremberg condena
los crímenes de lesa humanidad pero no
incluyen la violencia sexual y revisemos
la historia de lo de los testimonios sin
nur entonces
entonces lo que está pasando ahora es
algo que sucedió en todas las guerras
eso en primer lugar el consejo de
seguridad desde el año 2000 tiene la
resolución 1325 donde donde la
participación de las mujeres en búsqueda
de la paz y tiene la resolución 1820 el
consejo seguridad tiene una resolución
desde el año 2008 si no me equivoco a la
1820 y donde dice que la violencia
sexual puede ser una amenaza a la paz
que la seguridad fue el propio la teoría
para la verdad justicia y reparación
de naciones unidas dice que el
desplazamiento forzado es una violación
de derechos humanos que tiene un enfoque
en una visión de género igual que la
violencia sexual lo que está pasando en
la guerra en ahora en este momento no se
está hablando deberíamos realizar las
cifras que pasan en ucrania antes que
está pasando ahora y la violencia sexual
está pasando está ocurriendo hay
resoluciones para erradicar esto y la
pregunta que yo le hago y yo si quisiera
que fuéramos muy claros si la violencia
sexual si todas las guerras y no
solamente en la violencia sexual yo
pregunto y dejo esta pregunta si me
permite alguien se ha puesto a
investigar qué pasó con esos niños y
niñas nacidos producto de la violación
sexual en las guerras dónde está qué
pasó con las mujeres con forlasa más con
el confort en tokio que fueron
utilizadas y forzadas a prostitución
forzada para los soldados japoneses soy
alguien investigo con la justicia
sigamos con esas preguntas sigamos con
esas preguntas porque como digo la
violencia existía antes exacerba ahora y
por más acuerdos de paz lamentablemente
puede continuar si no no tomamos esta
carencia y preguntas necesarias además
para nosotros pensar que estamos
haciendo con nuestras sociedades con
nuestra humanidad
julissa de verdad para mí ha sido un
gusto un placer haber conversado con
ustedes sobre estos temas
lamentablemente se me acaba el tiempo en
televisión sabemos que es corto pero
pues ojalá tengamos una próxima
oportunidad para seguir hablando de pues
es todo lo que ocurre en materia de
derechos humanos en las mujeres en los
niños adolescentes y también pues en
toda nuestra sociedad julissa muchísimas
gracias
gracias a usted buen día un gran abrazo